speaking of moms one of the biggest
missions on our shows is to keep moms
feeling connected
and supported and heard especially this
year my goodness
and you know sometimes we just think
how do we even take a break when you
need it most and as a parent you put
yourself last
it's just a fact and so
we think about that here and when a
woman named melissa
reached out to us about her friend
angela
we knew that we wanted to team up to
surprise her in a thing we like to call
mom's time out hey drew i want to
nominate my girlfriend
angela she had cancer three or four
years ago
and then like six months later i was
diagnosed with cancer as well so we were
both going through breast cancer
and she was my rock she would come over
and bring me cards
and leave little gifts on my doorstep
angela lost her husband about nine years
ago
and she had a four-year-old daughter
that she had to
take care of whenever you see her she
just has that smile like that not only
is she a single mother
but she decided to foster kids herself
that's just the kind of person she is
and she'll go to our local restaurants
and pick up
soup or pick up whatever food that they
have
and she delivers them like all over i
mean this girl is
she's crazy i don't know where she finds
the time to do that but it's so
much a part of who she is when i say
angela i think of all the compassionate
things that she does for other people
and she never asks for anything herself
ever she always puts people first and i
think that is the most
important thing hi angela
i am uh so excited to meet you
how do you give back when you're being
this
example of such an amazing person
there's a variety of ways that i do give
back
we me and a partner run a christmas
program
to where we help families in need make
sure that they do not have
that they aren't forgotten on christmas
it's called community santa project
um i also help with my friends
oh yes there's the soup and soup for
seoul is one of the local restaurants
donated soup to us and we were able to
get it to
shelters as well as to fam local
families in need
we also help with a local children's
cancer
organization called cancer kiss my
cooley who was started by my
best friends after they lost their
six-year-old to a brain tumor
so i have my my
spread out a little bit but just enough
to
give me balance while raising kayla well
i
i would be honored if i could
participate
in your christmas program with my
daughters because i'm always looking to
find
the road to all the examples out there
especially during the holidays it's
such a time where we're so aware of how
important it is to take care of each
other so we would love to put that on
our website
all of your you know missions on our
website and help raise
you know as much awareness and funds as
we can
and you've been through so much
and lived such an extraordinary life
um a couple uh examples
is surviving cancer um
surviving the loss of a husband yes i
did
and yet being able to
be someone who really gives back to
their community
through all of that may i ask how
do you be the kind of person that you
are
i started out young my parents were very
giving and loving people
and i was raised that way and
i want to be the best parent i can for
my child and
the way to do that is by leading by
example
when i was pregnant with olive my first
child
i was scared of that notion leading by
example because
my example was you know a very
bohemian self-sufficient life and i
heard this story
on none other than oprah radio and oprah
said gail gail tell that story and she's
like i don't know why you love this
story so much and she's like just tell
it just sell it
and she's like i went and took my son
will to college and i noticed his dorm
dorm room fridge was empty and so i took
him to the local store to get a few
things and we noticed a traffic cop it
was like the heat
summer he was out there sort of you know
sweating and
we went in to get stuff and i came back
and i saw him and i went back in i got a
case of water and i brought it to him
why why do you love this story so much
and oprah said because in that moment
you taught your son what kind of human
being to be
and it gave me the faith i needed as a
mom with a baby in my belly that
examples were true and that they do work
but never in a million years can you
really
hold somewhat someone up higher than you
thank you drew thank you angela i have a
confession
actually um your best friend melissa
actually reached out to me
and she's here with us today hi melissa
hi angie hi melissa
melissa did you want to tell angela
something today
oh god i'm going to start crying um you
know how much you mean to me
and everything that you have gone
through and you're always putting
everybody
first and when i was diagnosed you were
the first person to call me
and like what do you need i'm there for
you
uh that that meant a lot obviously
because you knew what i was going
through going through it yourself
and uh just watching you oh okay i'm
gonna start crying
um you mean so much to me and i hope
that
you know that
thank you very much
it is such a beautiful thing and
really i'm just here to say we wanted to
celebrate
all the amazing work that you have done
for your community
and we'd love to treat you to an all
expense paid vacation to feed me for two
i hope that would be okay
oh my goodness that would be wonderful
okay great
and when it's safe to travel again we're
gonna send you in a guest
to yassowa island resort and spa
fiji which is tucked away off the coast
of
fiji's main island and they offer the
ultimate
in all-inclusive luxury and you'll be
arriving courtesy of the national
airline of fiji
fiji airways and by the way those
airlines are like having a trip in
itself and so from
when the car picks you up to the very
last minute of your vacation
we're just gonna take care of the whole
thing and make sure
it is nearly as perfect as you are so
this is our way of saying thank you
again
for being an example and the exceptional
person that you are this is a
well-deserved
mom's time out that's so amazing thank
you so much
drew thank you angela and melissa thanks
for letting me hang out with you guys
[Music]
you